A good ending can make or break a horror
movie. Fortunately for fright fans,
the 21st century has been full of fantastic
finales that have sent us scrambling under
the covers in fear—and from ghostly apparitions
to bloodthirsty vampires, here are the greatest.
And here's your warning: spoilers
for all these movies, of course.
The Descent has everything you'd want in a
horror film: plenty of gore, great performances,
practical effects... and
two endings? That's right.
There are two versions of this British horror
film, one released in the U.K. and one in the U.S.
The film comes to a close after our last
surviving character, Sarah spots a shaft of light
atop a hill of bones. Covered in blood,
Sarah makes a mad scramble for the exit,
leaving the cave-dwelling creatures behind.
Emerging into the sunlight, Sarah hops in a
car and makes her great escape, but that all
comes to a screaming halt when she sees the
ghost of her old friend Juno, a woman Sarah just
killed for having an affair with her husband.
That's where the U.S. version ends.
But in the original U.K. version,
there are a few extra scenes that reveal
Sarah never actually escaped the caverns.
That whole sequence was just a dream Sarah had
after tumbling down a shaft and hitting her head.
In her last moments, Sarah
sees her long-dead daughter
sitting a few feet away, greeting her
mother with a birthday cake. Of course,
there's no little girl, and the flames from
the birthday candles are really Sarah's torch.
Sarah is still trapped, and there's no escaping
the crawlers as they move in for the kill. But
at least she'll get to share her last few seconds
with her daughter, even if it's all in her head.
At first, it might seem like Let the Right
One In ends on an upbeat, romantic note.
Two star-crossed lovers — Oskar, a 12-year-old
boy, and Eli, a vampire who looks like a young
girl — have just escaped a Swedish town filled
with sadists and snow, bound together by murder
and romance. Light-sensitive Eli is hidden away
inside a box, but Oskar keeps the creature company
by tapping out sweet Morse code messages,
letting Eli know they'll always be together.
Think about it, though. We've already seen what
happens to people who pledge their lives to Eli.
In the first half of the film, Eli was
palling around with an adult named Hakan,
who hunted down humans and drained
them of their blood to keep Eli fed.
But Hakan eventually botches a job so badly that
he knows his arrest is imminent; he disfigures
his own face so the cops can't identify him
and won't trace him back to the vampire.
Eventually, the vampire shows up
for a late-night hospital visit,
and Hakan lets the undead beast feast on
his blood. That's probably what's in store
for Oskar. Sooner or later, Oskar will
dedicate his life to draining people dry,
and sooner or later, he'll find
himself haunted by his deeds
and replaced by somebody younger after ending up
the next meal for an undead adolescent. Bleak.
In Drag Me to Hell, a bank worker named Christine
is cursed after denying a loan extension.
In three days, a demon called the
Lamia will pull Christine into Hell,
and he's going to torture her every
second until that devilish date.
However, Christine discovers a way to escape
the Lamia's clutches. If she gives the cursed
button away, she can avoid winding up in the
underworld. Ready to get some revenge of her own,
Christine digs up the now-dead woman's grave who
cursed her and shoves the button down her throat.
Only there's one little problem. Christine
has been keeping the button in an envelope.
Unfortunately, her boyfriend has an
identical envelope with a rare coin inside,
and Christine gets the two confused. So after her
late-night cemetery excursion, she goes to meet
her beau at a train station, and that's when he
casually mentions finding the button in his car.
Terrified of what's about to happen, Christine
absolutely freaks out, staggering backwards in
shock, tumbling off the railway platform,
and landing on the train tracks below.
But before she can get mercifully squished by
an oncoming locomotive, the ground opens up,
and she's dragged into hell by a mob of
fiery arms. That's how you end a movie.
Resolution is a deeply unsettling
and underseen film about two friends
who are trapped in a real-life horror movie. When
graphic designer Michael receives a mysterious
video from his junkie friend Chris, Michael
decides it's intervention time. Michael drives
out to Chris's country cabin, handcuffs him to
a pipe, and forces his buddy to go cold turkey.
However, the intervention veers into spooky
territory when Michael starts discovering photos,
records, and slides all around the cabin.
They all depict incredibly creepy stories
that usually end in death, and things get
way scarier when Michael and Chris start
finding videos of themselves — videos that
show them getting killed by drug addicts.
The two eventually realize they're
the victims of an evil entity
that sees them as characters in a horror story.
The duo try their best to outsmart the beast,
and they certainly seem to. The druggies
who've been threatening them throughout the
film are killed, the haunted cabin is set
ablaze, and Chris decides to go to rehab.
It's the perfect happy ending,
one they hope will set them free.
As the cabin burns to the ground, the entity
rears its monstrous head and confronts the
two characters. Desperate for
another chance, Michael begs,
"Can we try it another way?"
And that's the end. Creepy.
The Babadook belongs to a very unique subgenre
of scary films: movies about parents who can't
stand their kids. The Babadook actually ends on
an upbeat note, unlike many others in this genre.
The terrorized mom overcomes her demons and
starts a new life for herself and her son.
Amelia was widowed the same
day she gave birth to her son,
Samuel. Now, whenever she sees her kid,
she can only think about her dead husband.
Needless to say, Amelia isn't handling her grief
well. She's let it fester and grow for so long
that there's now a fanged creature with a fondness
for pop-up books hanging around her house.
The Babadook even possesses Amelia, forcing her to
try and murder Samuel. But after driving the demon
out, Amelia comes to terms with her grief and
sends the Babadook scurrying down to the basement.
In the film's final minutes, we see
a transformed Amelia in her garden.
Her anger towards Samuel has disappeared.
Together, the two search their yard for worms,
and after filling a bowl with the creatures,
Amelia takes the dish down to the basement,
where she offers the worms to the Babadook.
Even though she's exorcised the beast,
he's still lurking down there, and just
like Amelia's grief, he'll never go away
completely. It's a chilling metaphor for
grief and anger, and a great closing note.
Horror movies often have twisted endings,
but the ending to The Blackcoat's
Daughter is just downright sad.
This atmospheric film follows two teenage girls
left behind at a boarding school. The semester
is over, but these two are stuck, their parents
nowhere in sight. That's perfectly fine with Rose,
a senior with a secret she needs to deal with.
But poor Kat isn't handling the abandonment well.
Thanks to a creepy dream about her parents'
fate, she fears she'll be left alone forever.
So naturally, Kat makes a deal with the devil.
The demon makes her commit horrible deeds, but Kat
legitimately feels at peace. After she's caught by
the cops, an exorcist kicks the demon out of Kat,
and even though she begs the spirit to stay, Old
Scratch drifts away, leaving Kat all alone again.
Years later, Kat has escaped from a mental
hospital and plans on returning to her school,
hoping to find her demonic buddy. Along the way,
she's picked up a middle-aged couple, who happen
to be the parents of Rose, the senior that Kat
decapitated back in the day. Things don't end well
for the distraught parents, but when Kat shows
up at the school with two fresh heads in tow,
the demon is nowhere to be found. That's when
it hits Kat that she'll be alone forever,
and the film ends with her crying
in the snow, abandoned by everyone.
Crimson Peak tells the devastating story of Edith
Cushing, an American heiress who marries charming
English aristocrat Thomas Sharpe. Sharpe is an
inventor who lives in a mansion ravaged by time,
a dying house sinking into the blood
red earth. And when Edith arrives at
Sharpe's crumbling estate, she learns she
won't exactly be the lady of the house,
as Thomas lives with his cold,
calculating sister, Lucille.
Actually, Thomas and Lucille are doing way more
than just living together. In addition to having
a physical relationship, the penniless siblings
have been keeping afloat by getting Thomas
hitched to wealthy women and then killing off the
unlucky brides. Edith discovers she's next on the
Sharpes' list, but a lovestruck Thomas agrees to
help Edith escape. Lucille offs her brother and
confronts Edith, morphing into a ghostly slasher
and fluttering through the fog as Edith holds her
off with a knife. Her ghostly brother distracts
her just long enough for Edith to finish her off.
Edith then leaves Crimson Peak forever, but
as our hero narrates over the final scene,
we see the dark spirit of
Lucille, sitting at her piano,
playing a mournful lullaby for time
eternal. Simple, but extremely effective.
The Alien series has never been a feel-good
franchise, but when it comes to downbeat endings,
Alien: Covenant goes darker than any previous
entry. The film focuses on a ship full of humans,
traveling the stars and hoping to wake up
in a new world full of new possibilities.
These sleeping souls have no idea the crew has
made an ill-fated detour to a nearby planet,
one that's home to killer aliens and
a psychopathic android named David.
We first met David in Prometheus, and his disdain
for humans has only grown since the first film.
He views people simply as subjects for
his experiments, and he'd like to run
a few tests on Covenant officer Daniels. She
escapes David's grasp with the help of Walter,
an android who's the same model as David, only
way better when it comes to his people skills.
After Walter defeats David offscreen, he returns
to the Covenant with Daniels and puts her into
cryosleep for their long journey ahead. But
moments before going under, Walter's kindly smile
morphs into a sadistic smirk, and Daniels
realizes this isn't her robo-buddy after all.
It's actually David, but there's nothing she
can do as he puts her under. With Daniels out
of the way, David coughs up two alien embryos
and strolls through the massive cryochamber,
admiring the pods full of sleeping colonists.
"Don't let the bed bugs bite.
I'll tuck in the children."
M. Night Shyamalan movies are always judged
on the strength of their endings. He's
occasionally struggled with sticking
the landing since The Sixth Sense,
but Shyamalan recaptured some
of that glory with Split.
This 2017 hit follows a
disturbed dude named Kevin,
a man with 24 personalities bouncing around his
brain. Some are friendly, some are dangerous,
but the dreaded Beast is a straight-up monster
— a cannibalistic creature who can scale walls,
bend metal, and deflect gunshots. In the final
three minutes of the film, after the climactic
showdown with Casey Cooke, we watch as Kevin
examines himself in a mirror, awestruck that
he's just survived a shotgun blast to the chest.
And that's where the movie proper ends, with
Kevin's evil personalities basking in their new
abilities and plotting their war on the impure.
"Let him show the world how powerful we can be."
That right there would be a killer
ending, but it's made even better by an
extra scene at a diner. The horrified patrons
are watching a news report about the Beast,
one customer is reminded of Mr. Glass, the mad
genius from Shyamalan's 2002 film Unbreakable.
And that's when we see David Dunn, sipping coffee
at the end of the bar and realizing it's time
to grab his green raincoat. In just one minute,
the entire fabric of the film has been changed.
Split wasn't just a freaky horror movie - it
was a stealth sequel to Unbreakable all along.
Mother is one part Biblical allegory,
one part environmental metaphor,
and totally disturbing from beginning to end.
Jennifer Lawrence stars as the titular Mother,
wife of a beloved poet known simply as Him.
However, their little world is threatened
by the arrival of an entire host of odd
people, intent on destroying their home.
Once you realize that Mother
represents Mother Earth and Him is God,
things start clicking into place. The film
rehashes several well known Biblical tales.
When Mother's newborn baby is murdered by the
masses, that's symbolic of Christ's crucifixion.
All the people Him has welcomed into his home
begin destroying everything in sight — desecrating
the planet Earth, if you will. And Mother
can only take so much abuse for so long.
After the death of her baby, Mother snaps
and fights back by setting the house on fire.
The house is burned to ash, the people are purged
away by flames, but since Him is an immortal
being, he survives without a single burn. The
all-powerful poet picks up Mother's charred body
and removes a crystal from her chest, taking
the last of her love so he can rebuild his home,
create a new wife, and start over again.
And that's how this horror show ends, with
the cycle beginning anew, all because Him craves
praise and affection for his literary creations.
"Baby?"
A Quiet Place was a critical and commercial
smash when it hit theaters in 2018,
and one of the reasons the film was
so successful is the fact that it
features one of the most memorable
endings in horror movie history.
A Quiet Place focuses on the Abbott family,
who are trying to survive in a world plagued
by monsters. These extraterrestrial creatures are
blind, but their sense of hearing is incredibly
acute. Knock over a lantern, trip on the stairs,
or shout in pain, and they'll slice you in half.
On top of that, they're covered in natural
armor, making them nearly impossible to kill.
As a result, the Abbotts must adapt
to live in a world without sound,
keeping as quiet as possible at all times.
Because the creatures' ears are so sensitive, they
can't stand the feedback from Regan's cochlear
implants. So when she and the surviving family
members are trapped in a basement by one of the
beasts, Regan uses her hearing aid to drive one of
the monsters crazy. It starts to writhe in pain,
allowing Regan's mother to kill the
weakened creature with a shotgun blast.
Of course, the gunshot attracts the other nearby
aliens, but the Abbotts aren't afraid. They've
got the upper hand, and as the evil E.T.s make
a beeline for the basement, Regan gets her new
weapon ready — and her mom racks another shell
into her shotgun, ready to make some noise.
For all its sci-fi trappings, Annihilation is very
much a horror movie. It's got hideous mutants,
extreme body horror, and uber-creepy plant
people. But perhaps the most terrifying
scene comes when Natalie Portman encounters a
mysterious being that mirrors her every move.
Annihilation finds Portman playing Lena,
a soldier-turned-scientist who's haunted by
guilt and regret. Her military husband, Kane,
has disappeared after venturing into the Shimmer.
Lena blames herself for Kane's disappearance,
as her bad choices might've driven
her husband to a suicide mission.
But a year after vanishing, Kane reappears —
confused, missing memories, and incredibly sick.
"I don't know where it was or what it was."
"How is that possible?"
Wanting to know what happened to Kane, Lena
joins a scientific team heading into the Shimmer,
which refracts and combines everything from
memories to DNA. She eventually winds up at
a lighthouse where she meets a metallic humanoid
that copies her movements and steals her likeness.
A horrified Lena tries to escape,
but the humanoid won't let her leave.
It even pins her against the door,
suffocating Lena with the weight of its body.
She escapes, but this is
where things get ambiguous.
Did the real Lena escape, or is this
her double? When she hugs her husband,
both their eyes dance and change colors, just like
the Shimmer. So is this the real Lena? Ultimately,
it really doesn't matter. The only thing that
does is that Lena has changed. The woman who
walked into the Shimmer has come out a completely
different person. Confusing but fascinating.
Upgrade is set in a near future where
most humans are totally cool with having
technological implants. One exception
is Grey Trace, but after a gang of thugs
kill his wife and leave him paralyzed, Grey
finds himself totally reliant on technology.
Thanks to an oddly benevolent billionaire,
Grey has been implanted with an AI named STEM.
STEM connects Grey's brain to his body, allowing
him to move around for the first time in months.
He's also oddly keen on helping Grey
find his wife's killers. Together,
the two stalk the streets, dishing out grisly
deaths to the crooks who ruined Grey's life.
However, at the end of the film, Grey discovers
STEM has been pulling the strings all along.
The AI desperately wanted to be human
and thought Grey was the perfect host,
so he turned the mechanic into a widowed
quadriplegic. And once he got inside Grey's
brain, he murdered anyone who knew of his
existence, from the killers to his creator.
Holding tight to his last shreds of humanity,
Grey fights back, desperately trying to save
an innocent detective. In that struggle, Grey's
mind finally breaks. His brain goes limp, and
STEM locks him away in a dream world, a paradise
where his wife is still alive. In some ways, it's
a happy ending for Grey, but also horrifying when
you realize that STEM has achieved his final goal.
"Grey's not here anymore, he's in a better
place, in his mind where he wants to be."
Hereditary is a tough watch of a film with an
incredibly deranged ending. Basically, the movie
follows a doomed family that's being manipulated
into bringing a demon named Paimon into the world.
He's been possessing a little girl named Charlie
for a few years, but Paimon would prefer to
possess a male, so his followers plot to transfer
the spirit into Charlie's older brother, Peter.
Of course, that involves a rather complicated
ritual where you have to decapitate Charlie,
host a disturbing seance, and set a man on
fire. In the last few minutes of Hereditary,
Peter is chased around the
house by his possessed mom.
Everywhere he runs, he keeps bumping into naked,
aging cult members. And to cap everything off,
Peter watches in horror as his mom
saws her own head off with a wire.
He's having a rough night.
It's all too much for Peter,
who throws himself out a window
and ends up getting controlled by Paimon anyway.
In the film's final scene, a possessed Peter is
surrounded by worshipful cult members, the
beheaded corpses of his mom and grandmother,
and a freaky shrine that prominently features
Charlie's decapitated head. Wholesome family fun.
"All I do is worry, and slave and defend you, and
all I get back is that f---ing face on your face!"
Mandy is a bloodsoaked acid trip of a
movie that blends a whole host of genres,
but in its heavy metal heart, Mandy is a horror
film. The film boasts Nicolas Cage as Red Miller,
who wants revenge for his murdered wife,
Mandy. Since we're talking about Nic Cage,
that means doing battle with demons and getting
into chainsaw fights with psycho hippies.
From the moment his wife is immolated, Red
begins to lose his mind. It doesn't help any
when he samples some of the world's trippiest LSD,
which plunges him deep into the cosmic darkness.
His eyes become fireballs of rage, and in
the film's final minutes, he hunts down the
members of the hippie cult that killed his wife
and puts his freshly-forged axe to good use.
When he finally confronts the
insecure cult leader, Jeremiah Sand,
he crushes the man's skull with his hands
before setting Sand's church on fire.
As the building burns down, for a moment,
everything is peaceful. The blood is gone from
his face, and he sees the spirit of Mandy riding
shotgun. He flashes back to the moment they first
met at a club, wearing identical T-shirts,
but then reality comes crashing back hard.
Red is still soaked with gore and grinning like
a madman. And as he drives off to nowhere, we
see two eerie planets hanging over the horizon. Is
this another world? Is it all in his head? It's a
truly freaky moment, and one that's bound to stir
up debate among horror fans for years to come.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.